TIME AGAIN FOR LEFTOVERS A
SEGMENT THAT YOU CALLED BETTER
THAN ANYTHING THEY'VE EVER DONE.
FINALLY THEY ARE BEING HONEST.
IT'S WHERE WE READ THE JOKES WE
DIDN'T USE THIS WEEK.
AS WITH ANY LEFTOVERS, YOU NEVE
KNOW AT THEIR GET INTO YOU DIG
IN AND AS ALWAYS IT'S MY FIRST
TIME READING THESE SO MY LAUGH
OR DIE FROM FOOD POISONING.
IN AN INTERVIEW AT 60 MINUTES
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN ONE
DEPRESSION PRESENT ABOUT USING
NUKES AND RESPONSIVE WHO IN ONE
TO BIDEN ABOUT USING BIKES.
NEW YORK CITY SHELTERS ARE SO
OVERWHELMED THAT MAYOR ERIC
ADAMS ADAMS AT MIGRANTS COULD B
HOUSED ON CRUISE SHIPS.
SAID ONE MIGRANT HAVEN'T WE
SUFFERED ENOUGH?
PHOTOS OF A TRANSGENDER CANADIA
TEACHER WEARING A GIGANTIC
PROSTHETIC AND CLASS WENT VIRAL
THIS WEEK.
WHEN OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL SAYS
THAT THEY STAND BEHIND HER
BECAUSE IT THERE'S NO ROOM TO
STAND UP FRONT.
>> ADMINISTRATORS WERE
ULTIMATELY GLAD BECAUSE SHE LET
THEM KNOW IT WAS TOO COLD INSID
THE SCHOOL.
>> WOW.
JOHNNY DEPP IS REPORTEDLY
UPDATING THE ATTORNEY WHO
REPRESENTED HIM.
ONE ASKED HOW IT COMPARED TO HI
RELATIONSHIP WITH AMBER HEARD,
DEBIT REPLIED SAME OLD.
>> YOU COULD SEE THESE COMING
BUT THEY ARE STILL FUNNY.
KIND OF LIKE MICHAEL MOORE.
THE INVENTOR OF THE SCRUNCHY
HAIR ACCESSORY PASSED AWAY AT
AGE 78.
HER FAMILY PLANS A PRIVATE
CEREMONY FOLLOWED BY LOSING HER
BEHIND THE COUCH CUSHIONS.
YOU TAUGHT REPUBLICAN STATE
SENATE CANDIDATE LINDA PAULSON
HAS RECEIVED A MIXED REACTION T
HER BIBLE CAMPAIGN RAP VIDEO.
FOR THOSE DOUBTING HER
CREDENTIALS, SHE CONFESSES THAT
SHE WANTS CUT A PITCH FOR
STANDING STILL IN HER POTATO
RECIPE.
>> I HOPE SHE WINS IT.
A NEW YORK WEATHERMAN--AREN'T
THEY ALL--AND HAS BEEN FIRED
AFTER SECRETLY APPEARING NUDE O
AN ADULT WEBSITE.
SOUND FAMILIAR, DAVE?
>> 'S BOSS LATER ADMITTED HE
WASN'T FIRED FOR OPPOSING NUDE
BUT BECAUSE HE LIED WHEN HE TOL
VIEWERS TO EXPECT 6-8 INCHES.
>> WHY DIDN'T WRITE THAT JOKE
EARLIER WHEN WE DID THAT STORY?
OH, YOU WRITE IT NOW?
>> A CUSTOMER AT A PENNSYLVANIA
RESTAURANT RECENTLY LEFT A
3,000-DOLLAR TIP ON A 13-DOLLAR
MEAL AS PART OF A SOCIAL MEDIA
MOVEMENT CALLED TIPS FOR JESUS.
IF I HAD A TIP FOR JESUS I TELL
HIM TO STOP SENDING ALL THIS
DINNER GUESTS ON THE SAME SIDE
OF THE TABLE.
WHO IS DEMENTED ENOUGH TO WRITE
THAT?
DID YOU WRITE THAT?
IT'S A GOOD WHEN A 27 -YEAR-OLD
MAN IN INDIA HAD TO BE
HOSPITALIZED AFTER SEEING A
METAL METAL TO CAN OF UP HIS
BUTT.
HOSPITAL STAFF BECAME SUSPICIOU
WHEN THEY TURNED AN MRI MACHINE
AND HE FLEW BACKWARDS ACROSS TH
ROOM.
AFTER HER SURGERY TO REMOVE IT,
THEY DESCRIBED HIS CONDITION AS
A ENOUGH FOR A MAN.
BUT MADE FOR A WOMAN.
A BRITISH MODEL WAS FORCED TO
CHANGE AIRLINE SEATS AFTER
FLYERS AND HARBROW COMPLAINED
THEY WERE GETTING CRUSHED BY HE
ENORMOUS.
THE AIRLINE LATER GAVE THE MODE
A VOUCHER AND SUGGESTED SHE TRY
DIFFERENT MODE OF TRANSPORTATIO
LIKE MOTOR BOATING.
>> TO BE HIRE AN EIGHT -YEAR-OLD
?
WE DID, DID WE?
AN EIGHT -YEAR-OLD BOY IS
WRITING ALL THESE JOKES AND THA
THEY ARE FUNNY.
AND FINALLY, MULTIPLE WOMEN WEN
PUBLIC THIS WEEK ACCUSING ADAM
LEVINE BUT SENDING THEM AN
APPROPRIATE.
THE MOST EMBARRASSING ONE BEING
I SEEN FROM A.
>> THAT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
I THINK ALL OF THEM HIT.
WHEN WE STARTED OUT, NONE